[Music]
[Applause]
uh got a new podcast another new podcast
including running smoke and it's uh with
Marcellus Wiley and it's uh set to make
its debut in The Dan Patrick Podcast
Network it's called more to it including
extended interviews across media sports
and entertainment I know Lil Wayne I
heard that episode that was very
revealing very entertaining uh Charles
Barkley Anthony Anderson Dion Sanders
Snoop Dogg Those are some of the
scheduled guests with that dude
Marcellus Wiley the former former
defensive end with the Chargers our good
buddy and here he is Mr Media good to
have you on buddy thanks so much Dan
how's it been brother everything's good
what do you have behind you what uh are
you in a year don't I have behind me I
think it's like every trophy I've had
since is pop warner pictures of the
family my book just as my my family
office right here so my whole Memoirs
everything's there explain your podcast
though what is it that why is this
different
yeah it's called more to it because with
every success story there's more to it
than what you see on the surface and if
you think about it I'm a big believer
that failure is natural and success is
sought and taught so if you wake up and
don't do anything we know you're gonna
fail at everything but these guys
whoever we're talking about the athletes
the entertainers the celebrities the
CEOs influencers they all have went down
a path of success that was met with
adversity and was met with resistance
and they still overcame all of those
obstacles and I think it's just
something that can Inspire us all
because sometimes you get down on your
luck and you can start throwing your own
pity parties but the difference between
a champion and a contender is that the
champion gets up one more time and I'm
trying to inspire all and you grew up in
Compton
yes okay
how do you get out of Compton and you go
to an Ivy League school
like how do they find you
um I think the discovery process is like
any other place any other Discovery if
you have enough Talent you make enough
noise they'll come find you no matter
where you are but uh my story I grew up
in Compton born and raised pre-nwa
before all the movies and all the music
before it got all of a sudden glorified
as something that it wasn't
um and then we moved to South Central we
actually thought we were moving to
greener pastures and it felt as bad if
not worse but I was a guy who had a
balance in that uh I had an identity I
knew who I was more importantly I knew
who I was not I was not a gangster I was
not a drug dealer I was not going to be
distracted by the ills around me I was
going to be focused and my two talents
frankly were my academics I was
intrigued about the whole learning
process I was eager to learn I was a
nerd and I was fast I was a fast kid I I
ran track I set National records I won
national championships and since I was
Fearless with that speed I played
football and that's all I had on my tool
belt man I didn't have a a ton of
resources or even it felt like a ton of
skills but I focused on them and honed
them okay but why not UNC or something a
little closer to home
yeah I think the short of it is I saw
too many of my friends Uber talented
five stars better players than me all
returned back to the neighborhood with
some kind of sob story some kind of
almost made it coaches tripping always
something that got them a little short
of what they wanted to attain and I just
frankly wanted to hire safety net I knew
I could play but who knows if you're
gonna make it to the NFL who knows if
you blow your knee up your senior year
who knows if you pull your hamstring
right before the combine and don't get
that opportunity so I wanted a higher
safety net and to me that was my diploma
that was my education and the reputation
of the school that I chose so I looked
at it as a simple formula pick the best
academic school and go play ball they
found me in Compton they found me in La
they'll find me at Columbia
Marcellus Wiley former NFL defensive end
and the podcast is more to it and uh
you'll find that on The Dan Patrick
Podcast Network so every Wednesday that
comes out all right as a former
defensive end you weren't a edge rusher
back then you were just a defensive n
give me what roughing the passer was
back when you played
oh night and day uh roughing the passer
was not only intent but consequence so
it wasn't just that you tried to hit him
hard but not only did you hit him hard
did you hit him late you didn't even
blur the lines of the rules you went
beyond the echo of the whistle and that
was roughing the passer back then so I
think it was pretty obvious in my day
what Ruffin the pastor looked like now
it seems like we're blurring that line
because it's not always done with the
worst intention and certainly not with
the worst consequence but then
protection of the quarterback that
floats all boats we know what this
business is about it's about that
quarterback Standing Tall and standing
protected so we have competing interests
everybody wants to still play the game
like a gladiator Sport and be physical
out there but you got to protect the
profits everybody like cashing them
checks well you got to protect the cash
and the checks that have been written
and those are the quarterbacks so how
would you play now
oh it's easy for me I hate when these
guys get out here like what am I
supposed to do I don't know how to play
in this game shut up all right all right
this is how it went they changed the
target area maybe like a decade ago and
guy after guy complained what I supposed
to do up and hitting people this way for
decades and they start finding them and
finding them and once they start finding
them those players start adjusting we
are Uber talented we see everything in
micro frames we can manipulate not only
how we fall but how you fall so everyone
adjusted the same with this all I tell
guys is look you get a sack on your
record on your resume whether you hit
them hard or hit them soft as long as he
goes down bruh and the sax is what you
want because that's how you get the
stacks that's how you get your money so
who cares if you're going out there and
make sure it's an exclamation point just
get the dude on the ground so he can
survive and we all get paid but what did
Chris Jones do wrong in his sack
what he did wrong is what his initial
intent and you got to watch it as I'm
speaking through it to actually get this
but Chris Jones was coming in to try and
lift them to try and DDT them want to
know why because his feet lifted off the
ground now when you're running you have
to have one foot on the ground in
contact you're running even if you're
running through someone you still have a
foot on the ground Chris Jones lifted
his feet you want to know why because he
was trying to get him down with some
intent and it wasn't positive but he got
bailed out I wouldn't have called Ruffin
the pastor on that one but I see why
they did it he got bailed out because
the ball came loose on the strip and
since the ball came loose then all bets
are off oh I'm Just landing on him
because the ball is coming out
underneath him but before even the ball
came out Chris Jones about to lift that
dude and DDT him and they saw that
quarterbacks certain quarterbacks
preferential treatment
absolutely uh like on certain teams no
matter who you are you're going to get
that preferential treatment it's the
pecking order it's the way it's supposed
to be uh you don't have a problem with
that that Brady and Rogers and Mahomes
are going to get preferential treatment
uh you know Derek Carr hasn't earned
that certain quarterback Josh Allen's
going to get preferential treatment
Justin Herbert probably Joe burrow
you're okay with that as a defensive
player yeah I mean that's the Dynamics
of the game that's the Dynamics of Life
Look Aaron Donald gets preferential
treatment he's a d tackle if you're the
man they're gonna show you love it's
just as simple as that and I was a
defensive end and I got preferential
treatment at the time look if you're the
man
in your locker room you just walk around
and your joke is not even funny and
they're laughing but you're not the man
you could be Eddie Murphy up there and
nobody gonna giggle that's how the game
works and it's the same on the field
it's not just the quarterback it's who
you are and your impact not only on the
game but on the bottom line so yeah give
them their love Yeah and Micah Parsons
has elevated himself into that like when
you you say who changes a game like how
many players truly change a game
Micah Parsons is on the short list
you could put Bosa in there I guess
um I don't know how many other Aaron
Donald you can put him in there miles
Garrett I thought was going to be that
guy uh but then mostly it's quarterbacks
as well but I I mean where would you put
Micah Parsons when it's when it's MVP
talk not defense player of the year I'm
talking about MVP yeah he's certainly
tier one
um and you got to respect what he's
doing because of how difficult it is I
mean it's one of the most resistant
paths in terms of making impact think
about it there's five guys in front of
you they're all 300 plus pounds and they
can move and a lot of times you get
double teams and even when you are
single team you make that impact Play
It's the timing of that play that really
has impact as a defensive end
quarterbacks are the ultimate because
not only do they get the yards but they
get the points and they control the time
of possession and it controls the amount
of possessions I've seen quarterbacks
when they throw for four touchdowns plus
they're gonna win 90 some percent of
those games I've seen defensive ends
when they get three four sacks they
still lose unless you can still get
spanked so as much as I want to
wanna we don't make the same impact on
the game as those quarterbacks how is a
concussion protocol changed over the
years
well one there was no protocol when I
played uh I swear so you didn't have to
lie back then no no no we ain't even at
the lie because they ain't even ask the
question to lie about uh it's so crazy
Dan like we used to call it getting your
bell wrong yeah yeah and and that's it
like concussion was left for outside of
football outside of sports like
concussion what you mean like if you got
knocked out that's knocked out other
than that it was just getting your bell
rung so now listening to the guys in the
protocol obviously it was a good
protocol but it's not a perfect protocol
because of the incentives I'm not gonna
lie if I were an active player right now
I would be incentivized to make sure I
never lost time because of the
concussion and everyone's gonna tell me
oh no your brain is different and you
got to take care of yourself in life
after football but I'm not thinking that
way I have a finite amount of time to
make this money make these opportunities
and go out there and ball so in
situations when it's concussion protocol
I am not serving the doctors I'm not
serving the team I am self-serving yeah
there's reasons why they're always going
to deceive because like Dan orlovsky he
said if I was 24 I'm going to lie
because I don't know if I get back in
the game again and then you're on the
bench he wasn't a marquee player here's
two of and that's what I didn't
understand if your back seizes up like
that Marcellus
the eye test means there's something
that really affected you maybe you
didn't have a concussion I got to sit
you out I got to figure out what
happened they just kept kind of pushing
it off going hey didn't have a
concussion okay but what did he have
that would force him to almost feel like
you know he just got hit by Buster
Douglas
yeah but you sound so logical and you're
sitting there in that nice studio and
that air-conditioned studio in a
different emotional state than a player
in that moment I had my back seized up
on me before and immediately I wanted to
continue to play and immediately the
doctor stepped in and said hey we have
to go through the proper test to
evaluate that I'm not mad at Tua if he
said it was my back and I want to go
back out there and play why because he
knows he is a French starter he's the
guy who's been hanging on by tooth and
nail and by a thread in that
Organization for whatever reason they
don't fully believe in him and he knows
he can't step away let somebody else get
hot and then lose his job
uh are the Rams in trouble
yeah certainly they're in trouble I mean
one they have the Super Bowl
championship fat and full going on where
okay everyone rubbed their bellies and
not only did they get their belly rubbed
they're in Los Angeles getting their
belly rubbed at sofa stadium so I think
that they're trying to get out of the
bed with the silk robes on like Marvin
Hagler once said and you can just see
that they're just a little off course in
terms of their eyes on the prize the
same appetite the same hunger going
through all those little things plus
Matthew Stafford doesn't look fully
healthy I talked to him about a couple
months ago and he said look last year I
wasn't healthy the entire year and I
think even after the procedure this year
he doesn't look fully healthy oh yeah
they're in trouble
good to visit with you and uh look
forward to your podcast it's called more
to it uh Marcellus Wiley and uh
available weekly on The Dan Patrick
Podcast Network great to have you on
board thank you brother oh thank you so
much Dan take care about that's
Marcellus Wiley we go back a long way
with Marcellus right when he joined the
uh right was he went bills then when he
joined the Chargers we started having
mine yeah I remember Paulie going hey we
should have this guy Marcellus Wiley on
and uh he goes he went to Columbia
and that's be right and Columbia
football was you remember how bad they
were horrible he stood out yes yeah